merci bonsoir je remercie pour l'intro
jeu oui je suis là pour vous parler de
la musique et du pouvoir de la musique
c'est vrai que la musique m'a permis de
côtoyer mes idoles comme l'a énoncé
présentateur mais moi aujourd'hui je
suis venu vous parler du pouvoir de la
musique dans le monde et la musique vous
l'avez au bout du téléphone portable
vous l'avez au bout de l'ordinateur vous
appelez-vous la télécharger vous l'a
transférée elle est virale elle est
facile elle est digital et moi je
voudrais aujourd'hui vous emmener en
voyage à travers le monde pour découvrir
le pouvoir de la musique dans le monde
parce que la musique fait appel à des
émotions la musique on utilise à dose
homéopathique
on utilise pour se calmer pour aller
faire la fête
enfin bref on choisit donc j'habite
marseille où j'ai été m'installer pour
étudier les musiques traditionnelles
parce que justement à marseille on a un
accès vraiment à toutes les communautés
tout le monde est là et moi je vous
propose d'aller faire cinq destinations
dans cinq de ses cinq destinations vous
allez découvrir cinq personnages hors du
commun
et là je vous emmène en inde alors il
faut savoir que l'inde selon la
mythologie indienne
c'est le dieu brahma qui a créé
l'univers à partir du sang rom et pour
commencer cette petite cet échange avec
vous je vais vous proposer de faire le
sang rouge donc le son comme ça fait
comme ça je veux compter jusqu'à trois
et on va se faire 4 5 secondes devant 1
2 3 merci beaucoup c'est très beau et
surtout ça nous permet de créer un
univers donc d'être ensemble de nous
réunir et moi j'aimerais vous parler de
tri tard une artiste que j'ai rencontré
à calcutta et qui se sert de la musique
pour revendiquer et pour parler de la
condition de la femme
on a tous entendu parler de la condition
de la femme en inde ce qu'elle subit
souvent être éteint elle se sert de la
musique pour parler de la femme
alors c'est encore plus émouvant parce
que ben la femme c'est la mère de
l'humanité
et je vous fait écouter un petit bout de
musique si ça veut bien
l'atterrissage
les annales
voilà alors en inde la musique classique
elle se transmet par voie orale elle
n'est pas écrite la particularité de
trith assez qu elle mélange aussi la
tradition et la modernité
donc là on la voit travailler avec son
gourou avec son maître c'est un travail
de toute une vie mais elle travaille
aussi avec des musiciens électro donc
pour faire une musique
alors voilà le travail d'autres états le
pouvoir de la musique de trith à ces
deux c'est de réveiller les consciences
ça c'est la première étape je vous
emmène maintenant aux états unis à
detroit pourquoi parce que j'ai classé
mes voyages par ordre vous allez voir
que plus on avance
moi je trouve que les sujets sont
prennent du poids alors détroit dans les
années 60
c'est la fierté et c'est la vitrine des
états unis des trois c'est la ville de
l'automobile
c'est la ville de ford et c'est le
symbole de la réussite
aujourd'hui 30 ans après des trois c'est
plutôt le le symbole de la perte d'une
ville parce qu'aujourd'hui cette ville
et elle est à l'abandon mais il n'ya pas
que des choses négatives parce que
detroit c'est aussi le label de la
motown c'est aussi la naissance de la
techno et quand je parle du label de la
moutonne je peux vous citer des exemples
c'est par exemple stevie wonder michael
jackson marvin gaye diana ross donc
c'est tout un vivier d'artistes qui
était comme ça au coin du quartier etc
ont été repérés et aujourd'hui c'est le
patrimoine de la musique de détroit et
c'est vraiment énorme
sauf que j'étais dans cette ville et au
moment où j'y suis allé c'est vrai que
en baladant dans les quartiers j'ai vu
que c'était une ville à l'abandon et là
bas j'ai rencontré un groupe de
musiciens qui sont passionnés de musique
mais qui ne sont pas musiciens
professionnels donc c'est à dire qu'ils
travaillent toute la journée ils ont des
jobs ils sont graphiste il son cuisinier
il son jardinier est une fois par
semaine ils se retrouvent pour une cause
pour réveiller leur ville
donc ils ont une fanfare là bas ça
s'appelle les marching band et ils sont
tous ensemble ils se réunissent ils ont
réquisitionné un quart des cols et y
partent aux quatre coins de détroit et
quand je leur ai demandé ce qu'ils
faisaient ils m'ont dit mais nous on
fait des attentats en musique c'est à
dire qu'ils arrivent dans les quartiers
n'importe où ça peut être votre
anniversaire ils vont
déboulé chez vous à 30 ils vont jouer
des trompettes de la percussion ils vont
aller au match de foot
ils vont aller aux matches de baseball
et ils vont célébrer comme ça dans
détroit et simplement le pouvoir de leur
musique c'est de redonner de la vie et
du sourire de la joie à leur ville moi
j'ai trouvé ça super beau et j'ai fait
une immersion avec eux c est suivie
alors voilà c'est à vivre de l'intérieur
c'est impressionnant et moi je trouve
que leur cause elle et elle est forte
elle est noble
je vous emmène maintenant à quelques
treize mille kilomètres de là je vous
emmène en afrique vous emmène en afrique
parce que pour moi c'était un pays
déclencheur c'est là que j'ai commencé à
faire de la musique en rencontrant les
gens puisqu'avant jeu j'étais dj's
bricoler je faisais un peu de
productions et c'est vrai qu'au contact
des africains quand je suis rentré en
france je me suis dit la musique pour
moi ce sera plus jamais qu'à moi comme
avant c'est à dire que j'ai vraiment
envie de me mettre plus en profondeur
d'enfer de chanter et et d'en vivre
donc j'ai décidé d'aller en afrique du
sud parce que l'afrique du sud c'est un
pays de tous les pays d'afrique c'est un
pays qui est différent de tous les
autres pays tout simplement parce que
c'est un pays qui a vécu un demi siècle
d'apartheid et la musique en afrique du
sud a fait partie de tous les combats et
elle fait encore partie de tous les
combats alors on a tous entendu parler
des manifestations à l'époque de nelson
mandela
c'était pour des inégalités raciales
aujourd'hui en afrique du sud ça
continue les manifestations mais s'est
plus posé des inégalités sociales faut
savoir que l'afrique du sud la richesse
de l'afrique du sud a été fondée sur les
minerais sur l'extra l'extraction des
minerais donc les mineurs il ya eu
énormément des neg alité sociale est
souvent il ya des il ya des
manifestations qui sont surveillés parce
que notamment en 2012 est un événement
majeur qui est arrivé il y a trente de
manifestants qui se sont fait tirer
dessus par les forces de l'ordre alors
ce qui est étonnant en afrique du sud
c'est qu'on manifeste en musique et ça
s'appelle le toît toît
alors c'est étonnant parce que moi quand
j'arrive dans cette manifestation à
johannesburg
au début on est en voiture on fait du en
fait ce qu'on appelle du repérage donc
on sait en cherche comme ça des choses à
filmer et je vois ça donc je dis arrête
toi je descend de la voiture et je pense
que c'est une fête de quartier
je me dis c'est la fiesta c'est un peu
sympa je vais fait promener photo je
vais danser avec eux et puis je pose des
questions j'y mais qu'est ce que vous
faites là est en fait les gens me disent
bennoo on manifeste on manifeste en
musique parce que ça fait deux semaines
qu'on n'a pas été payé et là on attend
le représentant des salariés qui doit
venir nous faire des annonces donc on
attend
en chantant d'accord ok et j'apprends
qu'en afrique du sud
en fait pour manifester pour chaque
émotion pour chaque requête pour chaque
demande
il ya une chanson une chanson qui date
comme ça d'un demi siècle ils s'en
servent encore aujourd'hui donc je
trouve ça fort parce que là pour le coup
le pouvoir de la musique c'est de
combattre les inégalités
donc ça aussi c'est au-delà du possible
on continue le voyage si vous voulez
bien et je vous emmène en corée du sud
alors la corée du sud je sais pas si
vous si vous connaissez trop ce pays en
tout cas la corée du sud c'est le pays
de psy cp du gang un style j'imagine que
tout le monde ici connaît le gangsta je
vois des sourires dans une musique oui
il faut savoir pour ceux qui connaissent
pas que c'est un véritable phénomène de
musique industrielle entre guillemets
c'est à dire que si à lui tout seul il a
dépassé les 2 milliards de vues sur
youtube
quand on sait que toutes les conférences
tedx en tout ça fait 2 milliards lui il
les a à lui tout seul
donc c'est un phénomène donc je me suis
dit je vais aller en corée du sud et je
vais essayer de comprendre un petit peu
cette population à travers le vecteur
de la musique est ce que j'ai trouvé à
faire comme une immersion là bas c'est
d'aller dans l'armée pourquoi l'armée
parce que la corée du sud ça fait 60 ans
qui sont en guerre et qu'à tout moment
ils peuvent partir comme ça au combat
donc j'ai demandé alors qu'elle
symphonique de séoul de faire une
immersion chez eux n'a pas été simple
parce que c'est très protocolaire est
qu'au début il voulait que je filme
juste un défilé mais je leur ai dit si
je suis juste un défilé germaine des
images de touristes moi j'ai besoin de
savoir comment vous vieillirez comment
vous vous entraînez ce que vous faites
au quotidien ou vous dormez donc les
huit généraux sont partis faire une
petite réunion qui sont revenus puis
m'ont dit ok tu vas venir faire une
immersion dans l'armée moi j'ai jamais
seul armé
alors oui j'ai fait des entraînements
entièrment chimiques
je me suis levé à 5 heures du matin pour
fais des footings torse nu dans le froid
mais surtout j'ai découvert que derrière
tous ces musiciens
il y avait des citoyens des combattants
qui était prêt à servir là en un site
leur nation et donc j'ai été voir le
chef d'orchestre que vous avez vu la ici
à l'image et je vais demander mais je
lui dis mais quel est le rapport entre
l'armée et la musique classique m'a dit
que tu vois l'alarmé en musique
classique il y a des règles il ya un
leader et un chef d'orchestre il ya des
interprètes et ça c'est très lié à
l'armée il ya une discipline et je vais
demander mais est ce que vous pensez que
la musique est une arme et j'ai adoré sa
question parce qu'il m'a dit non les
armes ses défis ses canons la musique
c'est pas une arme mais par contre ça
sert à doper le moral des troupes
donc j'ai trouvé sa réponse assez forte
même très forte je vous emmène
maintenant en colombie à bogota
alors la colombie c'est le pays c'est
vrai des clichés c'est le pays du narco
trafic de la drogue des tueurs à gages
mais c'est aussi le pays de la salsa de
la conga c'est aussi le pays de la
fiesta
j'ai rencontré un artiste exceptionnel
en colombie qui s'appelle césar lopez
qui est un guitariste et qui avait un
groupe à connotation très social
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sortaient souvent
dans la rue pour défendre la cause des
colons gains et là il venait d'y avoir
un attentat à bogota donc ils sont
sortis avec le avec le groupe et lui
avait sa guitare et il s'est retrouvé
comme ça nez à nez avec un soldat qui
l'a pas laissé passer et qui avec sa
kalachnikov
il a cassé sa guitare et lui comme il
est vraiment
pacifique il s'est dit mais c'est
incroyable cet homme en face de moi il
tient sa kalachnikov comme moi je tiens
ma guitare et là il a eu un déclic
il s'est dit je rêve de transformer une
kalachnikov en guitare électrique
chacun ses rêves mais ça c'est le sien
moi je le trouve assez dingue et donc il
a réussi à récupérer 20 kalachnikov ont
été confisqués au parc et avec l'aide
d'un luthier
il a fabriqué une arme qui s'appelle les
scoops et tara c'est une compression de
fusil et guitare
alors voilà je trouve son expérience
assez impressionnant parce que lui le
pouvoir de sa musique c'est d'amener de
la paix c'est d'adoucir les moeurs et le
pouvoir
on vient de voir que dans tous ces pays
la musique a un pouvoir mais la musique
c'est aussi un pouvoir c'est à dire que
la musique on peut aussi la subir ça
peut arriver
votre voisin qui met la musique trop
fort vous arrivez dans un magasin un
matin et la musique qui vous agressent
c'est possible ça nous faisait tous ça
nous est tous arrivé surtout à mes
voisins
maintenant j'aimerais vous parler de la
musique interdite parce que pour le coup
en faisant des recherches
je me suis rendu compte que pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais avant
aussi j'ai relevé cet exemple là mais
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
il ya eu de la musique interdite et
l'état nazi à éliminer des compositeurs
juifs avec leurs oeuvres ils les ont
listé ils ont considéré que ces
compositeurs faisait de la musique
dégénérée
parce qu'à répondait pas aux codes
artistiques de l'état nazi
donc je trouve ça très grave
j'avais envie de vous en parler parce
que c'est quelque chose qui m'a vraiment
touché et aujourd'hui pour ramener ça à
l'actualité
on se rend compte que l'état islamique
est capable aujourd'hui de détruire des
instruments alors je vous pose la
question
essayez d'imaginer une seconde qu'est ce
que serait un monde sans musique ça vous
paraît difficile parce qu'un monde sans
musique c'est un monde sans émotion
c'est un monde sans communication c'est
un monde sans communion c'est un monde
sans harmonie voilà et pour conclure
j'ai envie de vous dire que il faut
faire attention finalement à la musique
qu'on écoute parce que finalement la
musique qu'on écoute
elles révèlent souvent qui nous sommes
la musique c'est le langage des émotions
c'est un langage universel
c'est ça peut réveiller le monde et au
delà du possible
la musique elle peut nous apprendre à
vivre ensemble
au delà du possible et c'est ça le
pouvoir de la musique
merci